make sure to check out david pakman show
coffee and all sorts of other gear at
david pakman.com slash gear there's a
new bill which would force people to
give DNA and genetic testing information
to their employers and because of all
the attention that health care reform
and the russia scandals are getting
there hasn't been much coverage of this
this is HR 1313 called the preserving
employee wellness programs act and it
actually relates to something we're
doing here on the show i'll explain that
in a second the bill would force people
to comply if their employer wants them
to undergo genetic testing for so-called
workplace wellness programs and
otherwise they'd have to pay fines of up
to thousands of dollars making employees
do this is actually currently prohibited
under the 1990 Americans with
Disabilities Act as well as by a 2008
federal law which protects genetic
privacy and non-discrimination and the
previous law specifically says employer
health can't plans cannot require or
request genetic tests let alone
requiring employees to take them because
you could look at someone's genetic
information predispositions to certain
conditions or diseases and make them pay
more or maybe less for insurance
depending on the results and under the
same law if employees do choose to
voluntarily give their employers genetic
test results companies would only be
able to receive that information on in a
sort of an anonymous aggregated way
without being able to say okay here's
the specific information for a
particular employee this bill proposed
by Republicans would undo all of that it
will allow companies to coerce employees
into giving them their DNA and employers
can already conduct health risk
assessments and health screenings to
decide on how much to charge for health
care that's already allowed but if this
new legislation passes genetic test
results could be used to figure out how
much do you charge employees for health
care even if an employer doesn't provide
health coverage but has wellness
programs they would still hypothetically
be able to penalize employees who refuse
to give them their
information by taking the money of the
fine out of their paycheck
there's obviously privacy concerns as
well
employers almost always will hire
outside companies to do screening for
these types of programs and now you've
got third parties that would have the
genetic data on employees the bill was
approved by the House Committee on
education and workforce all Republicans
voted for it all Democrats voted against
it this is some of the most intimate
personal information which people should
be able to keep private and the
rationale for forcing people to hand
this over is not in the best interest of
the employee it's so that employers can
pinch pennies with health care costs and
charge certain people more the party of
freedom and liberty and individualism
wants to pass a bill which would
consider the withholding of genetic
information from your employer to be a
violation not of anybody else's rights
but your employer's rights
what happened Pat to removing
regulations and deregulating business
this is quite the opposite this is a new
provision of course it's one that is not
good for employees and is really really
good for employers I think this is one
of those examples also if Donald Trump's
antics kind of distracting away from the
real damage that Republicans are doing
because something like this doesn't have
the same appeal to a broad audience as
Donald Trump saying something ridiculous
at four o'clock in the morning and we
have to keep an eye on it because this
will impact people and does go against
consumer rights and the rights of
employees we're going to be doing DNA
tests so this is how it relates to the
show we've ordered and IIIi did over the
weekend my I spit into a cup a test-tube
and mailed it in and Pat had where're
you on it by the way I'm guessing you
haven't done it quite yet I haven't
started the process yet if you want I
can grab the kit and show the audience
yeah sure that that would be cool so
we're going to be reporting on our
lineage and I think the most interesting
thing would be if I have something
unexpected in my background
I sort of assumed that I'm almost
exclusively Ashkenazi Jewish by
ethnicity and it'd be interesting if
there's something else in there
but people have emailed me and said
David aren't you worried that now a
company is going to have your genetic
information and my answer was not really
but I can understand the concern are you
worried about that package no I don't
get too paranoid about that sort of
thing this is the the box that it comes
in and I guess you're supposed to spit
into this thing and send it in
I'm that I'm Irish and Lebanese but I
think there's a few other things in
there in my background as well so we'll
see we'll get the official results
pretty soon yeah six to eight weeks and
then we will do a segment and figure out
what's what